[Musique]
deux autres engins à rabat en moi
les eaux vaut ce sont les lieux de
prière des mongols les ils viennent avec
des écharpes de cérémonie des
porte-bonheur et les meilleures choses
qu'ils possèdent les offrant à la nature
et à l'eau vont en priant pour eux mêmes
leur famille et leurs amis
[Musique]
où
c'est le désert de coûts bucci dans la
région autonome de mongolie intérieure
est un lieu où existe une puissante
tradition nationale vaut la peine de
visiter cet endroit qui offre des
paysages exceptionnels atteint et pour
ressentir le lien avec soi même et avec
la nature a chanté and ipad
li fang est né ici dans le kobo çi après
avoir terminé l'école elle est partie à
pékin pour étudier à l'université mais
après avoir obtenu son diplôme elle a
décidé de retrouver ses parents sont
déserts et son entreprise pour moi
ouvrir mon coeur était la chose la plus
importante c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de
retourner sur ma terre natale et de
fonder mon activité ici ce film a été
tourné dans le désert de gobi çi il
raconte l'histoire de ses habitants qui
ramène à la vie cette terre aride
il explique comment en changeant les
choses autour d'eux les gens parviennent
à changer eux mêmes
[Musique]
je me rappelle que quand j'étais au
collège
au printemps il y avait des tempêtes de
sable avec de la neige chaque jour tout
était jaune en allant à l'école j'avais
du sable partout sur mon visage
même chose sur la route du retour bref
le désert a fortement influencé nos vies
toutefois nos charmants tous les
villages étaient situés près du désert
et chaque printemps des vents violents
venant du nord-est recouvrait les champs
de sable parfois le vent s'y fait tout
au long de la journée
à tel point qu'il était même difficile
de sortir de la maison
frontier noté t mn pour nous les
habitants le désert était un vrai
désastre
les gens du désert sont différents
tempéré par leur mode de vie
ce qui ne fait que démontrer que dans la
bataille contre les forces de la nature
les humains sont souvent perdant
[Musique]
la chine est le pays le plus peuplé du
monde et le troisième du monde en
superficie mais une grande partie de ces
terres sont envahis par le désert y
compris le coc bucci un million trois
cent quatre-vingt-dix mille hectares de
dunes incessantes constamment réchauffé
par un vent sec
[Musique]
mais on s'arrête ici
nîmes radiateur on y va nous pouvons
commencer
nous n'avons pas encore complètement
réussi cette partie ton âme vient en ami
si on bouge vers l'est ce sera trop loin
si on veut le faire comme ici ne
sécuriseront les plantes que pour un
temps
tiens tiens les mises à pied droit mais
pour le moment ce n'est pas assez ferme
où
le vent puissant déplace constamment
d'énormes tas table c'est le processus
de désertification un problème important
pas seulement pour la chine mais à
travers le monde
planter des végétaux est le moyen le
plus efficace de stabiliser les dunes
il ne faut que des outils de jardinage
est un instrument pour faire un petit
trou dans le semi mais tout comme au
cours des décennies passées
cela nécessite du travail manuel
[Musique]
celui-là n'est pas assez profond tiens
qu'il faut un trou plus profond peut
ressembler entier regarde si tu creuses
encore tu te rassure du sol humide ce
coup de chance on aide la pluie
récemment au quai la profondeur de ce
trou 50 cm à peu près continue à creuser
alors nous allons planter un arbre ici
les lignes directrices d'herbe sont
soigneusement tracé sur le sable ce sont
les signes d'une tentative réussie de
régénérer la végétation et de refaire
vivre la terre mètre après mètre plus
tard l'herbe cédera la place aux arbres
qui sont encore plus efficace dans la
stabilisation du sable les habitants du
coup gucci ont essayé tout un tas
d'espèces et sont arrivés à la
conclusion que le sol le peuplier le
pain sans racines le mieux nous sommes
déjà à l'arrêt suivant nous présent des
puits et produisons de l'énergie solaire
c'est important non seulement de la
lutte contre le désert mais également
pour changer le mode de vie de ses
habitants
il faut continuer à planter des arbres
développer le tourisme mettre en place
la production agricole produire des
plantes médicales et ainsi de suite
toutes ces choses dit mu l'économie de
la région contenir le désert et créer
des emplois dans ce qui n'est
probablement pas la partie la plus
développée la chine vise à aider des
centaines de milliers de fermiers et
d'éleveurs à sortir de la pauvreté
li but et a vu de nouvelles opportunités
dans le désert du kobo chili à près de
20 ans
au début mon père avait une entreprise
de travaux publics
ils construisaient des ponts des routes
il est gagné un peu d'argent avec ça
salim signal c'était dans le début des
années 2000 ensuite il a investi dans
l'immobilier dans l'industrie du charbon
quand il a investi presque tout son
argent dans le désert les gens ont cru
qu'il était devenu
non pas du tout compris un dossier
personne d'entre eux n'avaient jamais
pense à l'environnement et mon père lui
s'il pensait mais j'ai l'impression
qu'ils vivaient dans des univers
parallèles
ces gens là et mon père a tué leur
gauche
[Musique]
à l'âge de 16 ans la fille de l'ibu et
les fringues est parti faire ses études
à pékin elle est entrée à l'université
centrale des minorités pour étudier la
gestion touristique ensuite à
l'université polytechnique de hong kong
elle a opté pour un cursus international
hôtellerie restauration dans le cadre de
ce parcours elle a pu acquérir de
l'expérience en suisse et aux etats unis
avant de commencer mes études et de
quitter l'endroit où je vivais mes
parents et grands parents
tiens dit de bien étudier et de rester
dans une grande ville pour avoir de
meilleures conditions de vie et plus
d'opportunités
en ce qui concerne les conditions de vie
elles sont évidemment meilleure dans les
grandes villes
[Musique]
le tourisme joue un rôle moteur dans
l'économie mondiale et le tourisme
intérieur est en plein essor en chine
mais le désert du coup gucci ne semble
pas constituer un choix qui va de soi
pour un spécialiste avec de diplôme
universitaire en poche surprise quand je
leur ai annoncé que j'avais envie de
revenir
je lui en ai parlé assez souvent au
téléphone à l'époque où j'étais
étudiante comme tous les autres parents
ils m'ont demandé ce que je voulais
faire après l'université
je leur ai toujours dit que j'avais
envie de rentrer à la maison
rentrer à la maison et trouver son
premier emploi sur place signifie se
forger une réputation professionnelle
face à ceux qui vous ont connu en tant
qu'enfant
tout succès et tout échec ne passeront
pas inaperçus ce travail est important
pour la ville en plus de cela je le
trouve intéressant il ne limite pas à
mon développement personnel faire c'est
ici que je me vois évoluer
le désert du coup bauchi se trouvent à
700 km de pékin mais les vents secs et
violents peuvent facilement parcourir
cette distance au début des années 2010
les habitants de la capitale ont
commencé à sentir le souffle brûlant du
désert le long combat contre le désert
nécessité un effort supplémentaire et
ceux qui avaient consacré leur vie ont
commencé à bénéficier d'un soutien
gouvernemental
la nature ne doit pas être victime de la
croissance économique
tel est l'un des credo de l' approche
moderne des autorités en matière
d'écologie caractérisée par un slogan
chinois très typique les collines vertes
et les eaux pures sont des trésors
inestimables leur préservation est donc
dans l'intérêt du pays
[Musique]
la désertification est une menace réelle
alors nous plantons des arbres aux
confins du désert
cela crée ainsi une barrière contre les
tempêtes de sable jusque-là
désertification est devenu un problème
assez important pour pékin désormais
nous bénéficions d'un soutien
gouvernemental significatif et la
mongolie intérieure devient une zone
tampon pour le nord du pays
[Musique]
l'agronome youtube chine travaillent
dans des serres construites sur des
terres conquises dans le désert du coup
bocci la première serre a été construite
en 2007
maintenant il y en a 43 elle rappelle
plus un oasis qu'un symbole de victoire
de la lutte contre le désert
entrons et je vous montre comment faire
aujourd'hui nous déplaçons cette plante
[Musique]
il faut creuser sous ce semi creuser
comme ça juste quelques centimètres mais
ne l'en de magie pas la terre dans notre
serre ne ressemble pas du tout à un
désert joffre dans le désert il n'y a
que du sable
ici nous avons de la terre vous voyez
ces taches noires
si on prend le sable du désert dans les
dunes chantante
il n'y a pas de taches noires ce sont
les risques des substances organiques et
des micro-organismes qui nourrissent les
plans la conquête des terres sur le
désert a commencé en 1973 cette oasis
est le résultat de près d'un demi siècle
de travail acharné
la transformation du désert en oasis
peut prendre beaucoup de temps entre 20
et 30 ans car la transformation du sable
en terres fertiles demande la mise en
place et le maintien constant d'une base
de substrats solide
c'est seulement avec ce substrat que
nous pouvons faire pousser l'herbe dj
leur salaire et ruisseau qui traverse le
désert se jette finalement dans le web
créé le grand fleuve jaune de chine
le désert du coc gucci ne représente pas
seulement une menace pour les habitants
locaux mais a également un impact sur ce
qu'ils vivent très loin pour relever ce
défi environnemental majeur une
collaboration entre les entreprises
enthousiaste et les institutions
gouvernementales et nécessaire près de
160 millions de tonnes de sable seront
déversées annuellement dans le ranch
d'un guide chez trop limité l'érosion du
sol dans cette zone affecte le cours
inférieur du fleuve
c'est pourquoi notre gouvernement
surveille la situation de près
thyroïde l'objectif principal est de
réduire l'érosion des sols et de
protéger la rivière
décidément ça bleus qui causent des
dommages aux personnes vivant dans le
cours inférieur du monde
[Musique]
cela signifie qu'ils doivent continuer à
cultiver des plantes qui empêche
l'érosion des sols et la désertification
[Musique]
chaque printemps des milliers de
bénévoles viennent apporter leur aide à
la plantation
trente mille personnes sont venues ici
en 2019 mais toutes ont été prévenus que
de nombreuses armes ne fleuriraient pas
en raison du climat aride du désert
[Musique]
c'est un travail acharné traduit les
jeunes arbres ne survivront pas sans un
effort considérable le travail et dans
le désert est incomparable au travail
dans un domaine ordinaire dans votre
envoi de gens certains types de machines
ne peuvent tout simplement pas être
livré sur le site et le terrain lui-même
demande beaucoup de travail manuel à la
fois pour planter et arroser les jeunes
arbres en fait c'est même plus simple
comme ça
[Musique]
d'après les estimations de l'onu
les mesures prises ici contre la
désertification sont parmi les plus
efficaces du monde depuis près de 50 ans
les habitants et les bénévoles ont
réussi à planter de jeunes arbres sur
près de la moitié du territoire de ce
petit désert mais il reste du pain sur
la planche
[Musique]
la culture en serre au milieu du désert
est une activité totalement nouvelle
certains collègues de lieux justin sont
partis après avoir travaillé pendant
très peu de temps la vie dans cette
oasis n'est pas une promenade de santé
seuls ceux qui peuvent comprendre le
désert et se comprendre même reste
je suis né dans un village mais j'ai un
diplôme universitaire mes parents
espérer que je trouverai un travail
prestigieux pour ne pas avoir à labourer
la terre mais ma vie a pris une autre
tournure
je me suis installé dans cet endroit
magnifique et maintenant je fais de
l'agriculture organique au début des
années 70 quand tout ne faisait que
commencer
personne n'aurait pu imaginer que tant
de baies et de fruits pourraient pousser
au milieu du désert
maintenant c'est au tour des bananes
après deux ans rc bananier se sont
adaptés leur nouvel environnement
naturel du coup bucci
jeux d'adressé bananier sont désormais
plus résistant à la sécheresse et aux
maladies
il donne plus de fruits les jeunes
bananier ont pris racine dans un climat
de désert ils se sont adaptés à un
soleil ardent
ils sont devenus beaucoup plus résistant
en hiver le tourisme à kubot chi tourne
au ralenti mais en était un grand nombre
de vacanciers viennent voir les dunes de
l'un des plus petits des airs de chine
où est la caravane de chameaux
c'est là bas
li feng a d'abord étudié
l'administration du tourisme à pékin
puis à hong kong obuchi et son
université numéro 3 celle où elle
obtient une expérience pratique
j'ai vu beaucoup de beaux hôtels est en
droit auparavant chez participe au
travail des meilleures agences de voyage
international de retour à la maison j'ai
compris qu'il y avait beaucoup de
problèmes avec le tourisme ici en fait
nous avions beaucoup de problèmes tout
le monde était préoccupé
[Musique]
dès les derniers jours du premier était
de li fang en tant que gérante de la
zone touristique
en inspectant le domaine elle voit trois
de ses employées en train de fumer au
travail
l'étudiante d'hier se transforme en un
instant en patron exigeant
[Musique]
vous avez oublié ce que je vous avais
dit on ne fume pas vous pouvez fumer
mais pas en public
nous devons être au service des
touristes la qualité de nos services
dépend de votre attitude vous avez
compris son père a créé cette zone
touristique en 2010 maintenant il est en
train de passer les rênes à sa fille ce
n'est pas une simple transmission de
pouvoirs mais l'arrivée d'une nouvelle
génération avec de nouvelles méthodes de
travail
ma fille prend soin de moi
elle essayait d'aider prend certaines
choses en charge
mais là encore beaucoup de choses à
apprendre et en fin de compte ce n'est
pas un homme sa première réunion de
travail commence à 7 heures tous les
matins et elle ne rentre à la maison
qu'à 22h c'est épuisant major
les femmes patrons sont rares ici
conquérir la confiance des personnes que
vous dirigez et changer leur attitude
est presque plus compliqué que retenir
le désert
[Musique]
je réfléchis tout le temps aux raisons
de cela en fait je pense qu'ils avaient
plein de mauvaises habitudes
avant ils travaillaient sans grand
engagement
et puis fumer c'était normal mais
maintenant c'est tout est totalement
différent cette année nous avons
renforcé la discipline et il est
interdit de fumer
les fumeurs seront punis et on tombe pas
[Musique]
on
dans son vieux 4 4 li fang ramène son
père au siège de leur entreprise
touristique
c'est lui qui l'a lancée et c'est elle
qui prend la relève
il connaît tout le monde est au courant
de tout qui fait avancer les choses et
qui a dit difficultés remontent où
fonctionnent dans l'ensemble et où il
faut intervenir et le plus important ce
qu'il reste encore à faire dans le
désert pour améliorer sa région bien
aimé
jesse à la shoah cegetel c'est notre
nouvelle présentation
nous l'avons fait afin de permettre aux
clients d'avoir un aperçu rapide de ce
que nous avons ici oui dit il elle ne
sert qu'à sarkoshow terme qu'aux dessus
elles présentent toutes nos
installations montre en quoi elles sont
différentes des autres
est ce que nous en avons fait par
exemple on peut mettre l'accent sur les
dunes chantante et le téléphérique qui
est inscrit dans le livre guinness des
records
les quads sont une attraction à part qui
demande une attention particulière cette
année nous faisons le contrôle technique
des véhicules au quotidien et nous avons
aussi la bord et un plan d'action en cas
d'urgence en comparaison avec l'année
précédente
nous avons fait beaucoup de progrès en
ce qui concerne les quads pas seulement
en termes de sécurité mais aussi au
niveau des services le plus long
téléphérique dans le désert des
promenades à dos de chameau ou des
excursions hors des sentiers battus il y
a beaucoup d'attractions touristiques
ici mais cette dirigeante ambitieuse
n'est qu'au début de son parcours
avant on disait que le désert gucci
avait une influence négative sur la vie
des gens que c'était une véritable
catastrophe
elle était la réputation de ce désert
américain au cours de ces années grâce à
nos efforts
la désertification de notre région a été
freinée c'est pourquoi les gens voient
désormais ce désert non pas comme une
catastrophe
mais une source d'opportunités dotée de
ressources naturelles environnemental et
culturel
maintenant nous pouvons utiliser
davantage les ressources touristiques
que recèle cette endroit
[Musique]
cette saison touristique touche à sa fin
la trêve qui arrive permettra de rêver
et de penser à de nouveaux plans
d'affaires désert de sable
voilà un bon nom pour le futur complexe
touristique salon de thé résidence d'été
et yourtes mongoles restaurants et cafés
promenade et boutiques offrant une bonne
cuisine j'envisage de créer d'autres
devos mongol traditionnels aux tissus
it is je pense que ce genre de lieux de
culte transmet l'esprit de notre
entreprise à savoir notre engagement
environnemental à l'aide de nos nouveaux
produits nous pouvons transmettre aux
touristes un message sur la coexistence
paisible des hommes et de la nature âge
as tu expliquer aussi pourquoi nous
devons le faire et comment on peut
procéder au tir précis
[Musique]
cette année nous avons payé tous les
salaires à temps sans retard plusieurs
fois nous avons même payé en avant
science
bien sûr les gens étaient heureux mais
j'ai remarqué qu'à la fin de la saison
certains employés ont commencé à prendre
leurs responsabilités à la légère
surtout les plus jeunes pourquoi je
pense qu'ils étaient simplement épuisé
par le leur ils comprendront
[Musique]
il
beaucoup
e
[Musique]
si vous vous arrêtez au bon endroit et
grimper sur la bonne d'une vous aurez
peut-être l'impression de regarder dans
le passé
là où tout a commencé aujourd'hui c'est
un bon lieu de réflexion
[Musique]
je peux te poser une question c'est dur
pour toi
ce n'est pas facile comment arrives tu à
gérer toute cette inquiétude il faut
voir les problèmes sous des angles
différents
ce soit et chercher des investissements
bien sûr
in un sort aux battues a investi
là-dedans tout l'argent que tu avais
gagné ailleurs haïtienne
si tu n'as pas peur tu as trop bien bien
sûr je suis inquiet mais je pense qu'il
faut suivre le chemin qu'on a choisi
[Musique]
dans le désert un homme peut se sentir
aussi petit qu'un grain de sable mais
c'est aussi un endroit où naissent de
grandes idées et projets pour les bouées
et s'affilie fang le désert du coup
bucci représente beaucoup plus que des
problèmes et des tempêtes de sable c'est
une partie de leur vie c'est leur passé
leur présent et leur avenir
l'étendue de leur première victoire sur
le sable peut même être observée depuis
l'espace des oasis et de nouvelles
forêts sont en pleine croissance et
desserts ont même vu le jour
mais ce n'est qu'en venant ici et en
rencontrant les gens qu'il est vraiment
possible de saisir pourquoi il aime tant
leur terre natale et apprécier la beauté
de cette mer de ré de dunes de sable et
ce monument verdoyant à la persévérance
humaine
[Musique]